muito boa tarde obrigada por estarem cá
ainda portanto eu estou aqui quase como
um imprevisto
espero proporcionarmos um momento
agradável que vos toca alguma forma
a euronews falou em emoções e eu estou
muito emocionada portanto eu vou tentar
respirar fundo para conferir alguma
forma concentrar-me e ter um discurso
que vocês percebam é e eu não gosto
muitas palavras gosta mais de objetos e
de comunicar por objetos e criação de
objetos é a minha área expressões
artísticas e e aquilo que eu entendo eu
sou professora é que o que eu entendo a
expressões artísticas na infância que
essa temática mudou muito conhecimento
das minhas filhas
a resposta medina era passar aqui mas
pronto do boi tatá também deixem ficar e
é muito inspirado nelas e naquilo que
elas proporcionam am que outra um pouco
a minha visão sobre educação e sobre
aquilo que eu crio para a infância é que
o trago aqui hoje eu resolvi trazer se
este pequeno objeto mais visível aqui
conseguem perceber mas eu gostaria de
perguntar o que vocês acham que isto é
por isso que eu não criei um fluido
anterior noé uma nuvem
aliás isto é um filho da nuvem de uma
nuvem chamada miraldina que vive no céu
e que um dia estava lá no céu e olhava
pra viseu
uma cidade interessante cima então ela
decidiu fazer malas e bagagens e por
volta dos jardins efêmeros ela resolveu
até porque é é uma uma altura em que a
cidade tem mais pessoas e adora conviver
com pessoas e com crianças em especial
ela decidiu fazer malas e bagagens e de
tirar a terra com ela ela trouxe os seus
filhos que vivem dentro dela
portanto não vai miraldina chegou
jardins efêmeros e ram andou à procura
de um hotel onde se instalar
só que ela é tão grande tão grande tão
grande tão grande que não havia hotel
num e viseu onde ela começa socorro em
uma casa que foi intitulada pelos
jardins efémeros como casa do sonho
portanto será uma casa do sonho quando
nós tínhamos tudo é possível
então ela em controlar um quarto onde
ela que via
só que mesmo assim como ela é tão grande
tão grande tão grande ano nós não
conseguimos ver fora
temos que entrar dentro dela pra
conhecer
portanto este foi um projecto que
portanto o trabalho nas escolas para a
educação na área das expressões
artísticas e eu é ano ano passado eu
tenho uma filha de quatro anos e tem uma
de um ano portanto quando era mais nova
eu tive um uma gravidez de alto risco de
ficar em casa quase foi um período muito
difícil pra mim
ao mesmo tempo foi um período com
permitiu estar com minha filha mais
velha que ainda na altura era filha
única e eu queria aproveitar todos os
momentos dela como filha única porque
isso nunca mais iria acontecer aliás
todos os nossos filhos são únicos né
mas depois desse período eu fiquei do
licença dá licença de parto portanto
fiquei praticamente 12 mestre
fora da escola quando eu regressei ao
trabalho
a doutora cristina presidente da escola
superior de educação antonino eu entrei
no final do ano letivo as pessoas que
estavam substituídos iriam continuar até
o final
portanto como normalmente escolas
provocação colabora com os jornais
efêmeros e como vi esta proposta da
escola ter um espaço dedicado à infância
ela am sugeriu este desafio que eu
adorei me envolvi é temática era a luz
era luz e eu e pronto não é que surge é
a us portanto eu comecei a juntar luz
casa do sonho infância o que poderá
chegar aqui comecei a pesquisar é o
próprio conceito de luxo autores
artistas plásticos que trabalhassem essa
temática e cheguei a um ponto em que eu
pensei assim fará mais sentido seu
partido dá alguma coisa dá alguma
memória da minha infância e ocorre um
câmbio eu passei na rua com as minhas
filhas e nós temos sempre uma visão
todos vocês todos nós no nosso dia-a-dia
anos sempre muito em frente o horizonte
nesta direção
hoje em dia olhando uns muito pro chão e
normalmente não paramos ou não deitamos
de barriga procel e olha o céu e
observamos as nuvens e as chuvas também
nos contam histórias é e então eu sempre
ouvi na minha infância a expressão
maratuã das nuvens anda sempre nas
nuvens ou anda sempre com a cabeça na
lua
e quando nós andamos nas nuvens nós para
nós tudo é possível nós tínhamos nós
podemos ser tudo aquilo que nós
quisermos então partiu muito daí
é parte muito da yoki ficou decidido
através de uma equipa de trabalho que
depois organizou na escola com
diferentes cursos
então começamos a discutir idéias e
surgiu a idéia da nova e vamos instalar
uma nuvem nos jardins e ferros extra
isso o espaço dá exemplo eu comecei a
trabalhar nisto e pronto terão ter um
filho é muito diferente ter dois
a questão da gestão do tempo é muito
difícil então eu comecei a levar a minha
filha mais velha fica mais nova ainda
era muito pequenina como saiu vala
comigo para o espaço
e ela é fã
eu falava com ela sobre a idéia e
conversávamos é e ela am também agora as
suas ideias e questionar e então é agora
voltar atrás
é esta obra também foi inspirada na obra
do do rei magri 30 no cine pe
isso não é uma nuvem porque nós numa
representação plástica gráfica nós nunca
conseguimos apresentar a verdadeira
essência das coisas é impossível
apresentar mas nós podemos sentir lá e
vivê-la e é que o que eu pretendia criar
um espaço que envolve essa criança de
uma forma mais sensorial e falou saque e
ângulos falou ano espaço natural não é o
o o espaço mais rico em termos das
sensações é mesmo espaço natural da
natureza né
mas acho que podem existir um equilíbrio
entre os dois entre o espaço natural
espaço artificial sempre inspirado no
espaço natural portanto am
agora vou posar aqui não vêm porque ela
pode ficar assustada que estou mentindo
portanto aquilo que vos vai mostrar a
andar nas nuvens
fui ué
quito que atribui para aqui para este
até de mexes juan
o projecto chama se isso não é uma nuvem
e aquilo que eu vou falar e estou a
falar e das memórias da minha infância
ano e de envolvência das minhas filhas
na criação deste espaço
porque para mim seu envolver aquilo que
eu vivi com elas todos os dias na minha
parte profissional também as coisas
fazem todas muito mais sentido e tem
sempre aquela capacidade de sonhar
sempre não parar porque elas as crianças
são elas têm oportunidades e fui simão
pode estar aqui e isso mas nós temos que
olhar para elas e temos que ajudá las a
ser influência importante é que eu vou
estar aqui são imagens e alguns vídeos
culpa pela má qualidade porque muitos
foi foram fotografados e filmados com o
meu telemóvel porque não havia outra
possibilidade é que vocês vão ver aqui é
um pouco o ato por imagens e vídeos
daquilo que foi a envolvência de aula
principalmente a mais velha
neste processo criativo é que eu fui o
primeiro cartaz foi feito num quadro ver
dose em casa no meu terraço com ela na
altura era verão
ela estava sempre a dizer mas não se
parece com uma luva isso não é uma nuvem
tentava ir lá ela muitas das fotografias
era com as mãozinhas dela à frente
esta foi retirada do cartaz
esta é a sala de exemplo e esse era um
pouco a parte conceitual do projeto isso
não a nuvem é um espaço para ser feliz e
eu acho que isso é o mais importante
para além do espaço para crianças eu
acho que é isso notou-se depois dos
resultados os adultos também se
envolviam muito e eu tenho é que o caso
daquelas pessoas que visitaram a nuvem
com o filho i e ii e lúdico
crianças a um espaço dedicado à infância
as crianças mas também a volta e que
pensa em sua infância
portanto estas são as minhas duas
colaboradoras principais para além da
equipa de exemplo que trabalhou comigo
sempre na concessão
elas são as minhas principais
colaboradoras e fonte de inspiração é
que em maria nunes início ele este é
parte inicial portanto que são tubos de
cola quente e ea é um rodopio manta que
estava a iniciar o corta ela dizia que
aquilo era um ovos é ela não imaginava
que o pudesse vir a ser uma nuvem e ela
neste momento ela estava a brincar e
explorar e e karnak e perceber o que era
aquilo é entretanto ela brincava durante
enquanto eu ia trabalhando não é ela e
brincando com aquilo que encontrava ela
pegava uma tesoura e recortava também
ela colocava o chico os todos por hora
vem e ela saltava em cima dos circos
como se fossem pedras no rio por exemplo
e isso deu origem a que a nuvem tivesse
pedras do rio dentro da barriga é que
está ela a correr saltar e credo pular
em cima das pedras do rio aquela eto'o
também houve momentos de conflito ela
neste momento pronto trabalhar com
crianças é os pais querem também ela
neste momento tenhamos que ir embora ela
não cria é e aqui era a experiência de
uma das filhas da nuvem já instalada no
teto
quando o espaço começou a estalar tanto
começou a ser um pouco mais difícil de
tê la comigo porque pronto havia am ou
eu estava concentrada mais nesta parte
da construção ou então tinha que estar a
perceber se ela estava pegar em alguma
coisa que fosse perigosa etc
e já que falamos em família tá ali um
pouco o perfil da minha mãe que também
se deslocou do amigo ao xii semana para
me ajudar
assim que o margen as irmãs e etc
este espaço que portanto nós entrávamos
na nuvem e depois da nuvem havia um
espaço que era um carrossel com luz uma
estrutura metálica onde nós normalmente
vocês quando estão a observar as nuvens
normalmente o que vêem
fog formas animais
de uma forma geral vimos animais então
haviam recorta vários animais instalados
nesta espiral onde as crianças podiam
mover e que era um carrossel que
projetava todas essas sombras que eram
as sombras das nuvens mas que eram
animais é que esta é a experimentar o
que também foi ótimo antes de abrirmos
ao público para as crianças ela
experimentou tudo pra ver se estava tudo
impecável para então é essa e outras
crianças poderem também brincar
aqui um pequeno vídeo
aqui não vi já estava um pouco mais
instalada esta é uma das colegas que
trabalhou comigo na concessão deste
projecto e ela estava a espreitar a
janela porque é nuvem miraldina trouxe
alguma roupa durante a viagem como
querem sujar então levamos a roupa
estendemos lá fora da janela
este é um espaço completamente
construído e criado não dá pra perceber
muito bem portanto o que aconteceu aqui
ela depois de estar lá dentro ela dizia
mas então estamos dentro de uma nuvem
onde estava o que revela onde está ela
fala ana estudo onde estava o que revela
alguma ideia podemos dar de beber à
nuvem ou de comer a nuvem
então por que o espaço seria só era um
espaço sensorial onde estava tinha
vários objetos que com o som várias
texturas e então a partir daí é aquilo
era um pedaço é um órgão da nuvem que
era um túnel onde eles podiam passar ela
tenha mesmo uma barriga com vários
objetos é um estômago desculpa um
estômago das pessoas crianças podiam
apalpar e perceber que aquela tinha
comigo há também um vídeo com o som
é a minha garrafa de algo dentro do
estômago há alguns dias e mandou no
ângulo 1 a a garrafa o do barulho algum
tempo li uma garrafa e tudo que eu
sentia um lá várias texturas é que é
mais nova também está a experimentar é
que então do bicho foi em casa já então
vamos dar de beber a água como é que
vamos lá vamos dar de beber à nuvem
então como é que vamos fazer isso então
comecei a experimentar através de um
retroprojetor
como é que poderia ser esse que também
ela é a interagir ia perceber o que ela
estava com medo é que são as duas filhas
viviam dentro da barriga
o evento ainda não tem todos aqui já é
uma imagem já de uma das oficinas ampara
crianças já no interior da nuvem onde
aconteciam também histórias aqui também
um vídeo é que entrada de um grupo de
crianças na nuvem está conforme foi
filmado até pra você não dá pra ver as
pressões deus
em uma luz negra e energia
aqui também
ela que estava pela água e comer
normalmente quando eu colocava corante
alimentar para melhor desempenho logo da
boca que ela estava comemorando
este era um sonho no interior da barriga
não foi a noite de ontem o promotor
agora tem que ganhar aqui e ali o ok
também ouvido uma chapa para terminar
para mim é este projecto foi muito
enriquecedora e acima de tudo am
espero que você está inspirado dá alguma
forma e agora para concluir vamos ficar
com o vídeo foi feito pelo exemplo com
um apanhado geral daquilo que foi a
nuvem
obrigada